some good news this morning for the
hospitality industry
after nine long months the rio finally
reopens today here in just a few hours
bianca holman live for us this morning
with those details hi bianca
hey good morning alex the rio will be
open every day between the 23rd
and the 3rd of june allowing guests to
stay there and then once they're into
the new year
they will only be open and serving
guests at the hotel part of the property
thursday through monday now we're told
that the gaming floor will remain open
seven days a week even into the new year
and this is the last
caesars entertainment property resort in
las vegas to reopen today
the resort will also debut its newly
branded william hills sportsbook
it features self-service sports betting
kiosks and expanded betting menu
featuring
live in-play wagering tourists believe
there's still a great deal of interest
in visiting las vegas
people want to be here now more than
ever because
i mean this is one of the only places
you can enjoy now it may be wrong that
we came but i mean we're actually taking
precautions you know we're taking care
of ourselves
so self parking at the hotel and casino
will be free but the valet will remain
closed due to safety precautions
and as the property reopens they hope to
bring some holiday cheer to their team
members of course probably excited to be
back at work and they got a special
giveaway for them
of course we'll be there and featuring
that in our later newscast and online
reporting live from near flamingo and
valley view bianca holman 8 news now